he's a six-time pro bowler and uh since
retiring from the national football
league all he has done is put together
an incredibly popular show and podcast
called i am athlete and you can catch it
on the i am athlete youtube page at im
athletetv.com which is the website
associated with it as well
and uh he's got antonio brown coming up
on monday and uh we figured let's talk
playoffs and his show with brandon
marshall how have you been brandon
marshall
i am awesome
i love you and i miss you right back
before we before we go to antonio brown
and all the other stuff i want to talk
about what you just did what did you do
you covered all of us a lot of us
from college to retirement coach career
you know i'm getting old
yes you know listen that should be it i
didn't feel the positivity in that
right like i'm reading this book right
now i actually just cracked it open
right now i mean call though it's called
half time
i bob beautiful right and it's about how
you go from moving from success to
significance and it's important it talks
about half time okay now we're in this
transition
and in the second half of our life
this is when we can get even more
creative and have more success but in a
significant way i think you need to
check it out
well brandon i i appreciate that um and
i appreciate you saying that and i
always one of the many reasons why i
love talking to you is your
thoughtfulness and your
your brain man and um
the only difference though is i've lost
all my hair your hair looks great you
know what i mean like you got to
understand where i'm coming from here
all right i'm also a neurotic jewish
person
you know you played in new york around a
lot of us
you know i mean i don't know if there's
anything in halftime about that is there
anything
you know
no no no
oh
i miss you buddy right back at you right
back at you all right uh i i always
shoot you straight sir uh uh after
antonio brown said what he said about
tom brady and and and said what he said
after strip sacking himself i came on
the show i said i am done with him i'm
done talking about him i think he needs
help and people need to get him some
help that's what i said and you know i
don't throw those words around lightly
at all okay
um you know i wore a green tie because
you helped me one year in my 40-yard
dash in in honor of your
your movement and your your work uh in
in uh for mental health awareness so i
don't throw those words around lightly
but when i heard you interviewed him i'm
like okay
i'll bite on this
so why did you why did why did you
interview him why do you want to talk to
him yeah
well first i think that um we're curious
you're not the only ones i want to
validate that you know there's i have
some friends that text me
and they're like why are you sitting
down with him you know he needs help
um
you know people keep enabling him
and so for me
i'm curious i'm and i'm curious to have
this conversation in the locker room
setting and that's pretty much what
we've created that i imagine is just
that locker room talk yes in the locker
room you have people from different
walks of life have different points of
views right and we have you know
discussions on a wide range of topics
and so
it's a special thing that happens in the
locker room where we're able to
you know hold guys accountable
um
because you're part of this locker room
this fraternity in the locker room we're
able to get into intense conversations
and in discussions
and still hug at the end of it right
because we have a common goal that's to
win a championship so you learn these
interesting things in the locker room
and we're able to have discussions with
each other that we can't even have with
our wives
our children our moms and dads right
just a special bond so i was curious to
see how you responded in that locker
room setting and i mean it was a
conflict i'd be honest with you it was a
it was a it was a complex conversation
it was a difficult conversation hell
there was one part of the conversation
rich when i was like i feel like you're
interviewing me now and that's not the
job like i'm now can i can i do my job
in the second half of my career it was
really complicated right and it's
somebody who interviews people for a
living as i have for as long as i had
normally that's the sign of somebody who
wants to avoid answering questions
to be honest with you man right like
that that's somebody who's just like
okay you know i understand that you know
this may be difficult but you're the one
who agreed to sit down
and and you know
so you asked him at one point if you
think he needs mental if he has a mental
health problem and he said no do you
having chatted with him would you agree
with that assessment
here's what i would say just being a
high profile after you came into nsf for
13 years
i would say that
you know when
there's a there's a consistent behavior
or a pattern that would say
um
you know i think the
you know there should be a time you know
in your journey when you sit down and
you ask questions you'd be curious you
look yourself in the mirror and
potentially go sit down with someone and
see what is going on with me
and if there's nothing going on with you
i still think that you should talk sit
down and talk to someone because there's
so much pressure during the 16 billion
dollar business you have multi-million
dollar athletes you know you have people
pulling on you every single day you know
you can get cut any moment you could be
boozed in front of the world any moment
or chair there's a lot that you have to
deal with at the age of 22 24 30 32
years of age and so i think that whether
it's an impairment or performance issue
i think you should be talking to someone
so if i you know for me
you know as a brother you know i would
say i would i would grab antonio brown's
hand and say you know let's just sit
down with someone to see you know uh how
we could potentially right you know
navigate through the situation
you know a little bit better right yeah
but he but to be honest with you he
that's what he said you saw it you saw
it you saw the snippet there's nothing
wrong with me this thing thinking is
this it's like
you know okay brandon you know where i
come from this is how we respond
right i'm not a passive aggressive
person
bruce aryan who's now back in the media
hitting that player adams who i played
with safety
you know looked at antonio brown and
said get the ass out of here and get the
little uh throat slash and thing like
you're done
right
and so for him
the only thing i'm thinking about in
that situation is this person said you
want me here so i'm leaving right now
i'm gonna wear your logos
so
there's rationale behind his thinking
right
and so um
you know he he he he has a lot of
answers for for
issues of certain situations that he's
been in
no i i i understand that i got brandon
marshall here uh on the rich eisen show
and that you know
hey man i i i are you saying he's not
he's not seeing a therapist like he uh
on on i say this
sharing with you and everyone here uh
i'm i have a weekly session myself i'm a
52 year old father of three you know a
husband
uh a son
you know lost a dad there's so much
going on and i i i'm talking to one in
two hours from now for a weekly session
he's not speaking to anybody
brandon right is he not because that's i
i
yeah
somebody's got a again
look
um
and and part of this too uh again and
when you interview him i i don't mean
that you own everything that he says
okay but you know
to me that part of his
post
you know um
reaction to everything okay
is to is to try and get more famous it
seems like is that wrong is that a wrong
thing because the video that i see
everywhere is him hanging with madonna
and kanye and that got millions of views
is this something that he wants
you know right well yeah
to answer your first question right like
what i took from the interview uh one
the confident guy
um
seems to be strong
and uh i don't think he's talking to
anyone um
you know
and and i'm so glad that you mentioned
that you talked to someone weekly i
still talk to someone weekly i'm sure
you know sometimes now it's shifting in
this transition second half of my career
i thought sometimes it's twice a week
you know because there's a lot of
pressure when it comes to business and
entrepreneur being in the media a
husband and a father there's so much
that happens right yeah so i i'm with
you i think he should be
talking to someone
and um whether he's dealing with
impairment issues walking around with a
diagnosis or just performing
and uh
that is fair
it's fair yes uh
um you know antonio brown this is deeper
conversation right like
athlete the challenge is when you are an
athlete in a team sport
team comes first
but now over the last six years even
going back to when he was in pittsburgh
remember he was going to practice with
cameras he was flying in on helicopters
pulling in and drop top 1940s
royce cars it was always a show for
antonio brown which was being deviant
behavior back then
right
so antonio brown has always been one
that said you know what i understand
team but i'm coming here to do my job
and at the same time i'm going to put on
the show and i'm also going to build up
my brand and tell my story the way i
want to tell my story so absolutely he
did it in in his first podcast he said
it you know i think the met life
incident where he came out and he said
look
that song was already
produced i i did that song two years ago
but then there was a moment all eyes on
me
now we're talking about algorithm right
like i think it's hard for some people
like us right but we're learning we're
all social but we're still not like
right as good as that the generation
behind us like look it was a perfect
time to drop my song
and he sees it as a moment he sees that
this could be uh he's
he he can he's not playing around with
entertainment antonio brown
really
is embracing being a rapper
so
you know i know it's hard for for a lot
of us to understand and gather because
like that's antonio brown the the hall
of fame wide receiver that's the guy
that had seven
seven pro bowl one to seven pro bowls
what is he doing rapper what is he gonna
sit down with madonna after you leave
met life stadium
what was supposed to do is you told it
quiet don't say anything right
that's what we're used to seeing in
these moments and and
we're not right now
brandon marshall here on the rich eisen
show before i let you go on your rest of
your friday again this antonio brown
interview is going to air on the im
athlete youtube page
um on monday you got thoughts on who
makes the super bowl
two cents on that one
switching gears super bowl yes sir man
listen i forget i think i'm like i feel
like i'm like michael irvin your buddy
like i feel like he changes his picks
throughout the year all the time
i yeah i changed my picture yeah right
mike
um yeah yeah so yeah right so i i don't
know who i picked at the beginning here
who i picked halfway through here for
you to go right now
i'm a big fan of buffalo i've been on
them for two years
uh fighting with nick wright about josh
allen how awesome he is so i think they
can get it done
um that defense have to stand up against
patrick mahomes they didn't play smart
enough meaning more
i don't want to dead guys i don't think
we have time for me to dive deep into
football right
all right so i like buffalo and then on
the
on the nfc side
tom brady's great man but
i don't know aaron rodgers won super
bowl
that green bay packers have wasted the
aaron rodgers era
terror for sure
we're talking about the last band
like if this is the last dance they have
they have to go out with a super bowl
victory that's true we have to hold the
lombardi trophy so i'm going with
buffalo and i'm going with green bay for
last man i'm not a huge fan of
everything aaron rodgers does but
there's something special about what's
going on in that locker right now
you know them versus the organization
well brandon uh appreciate the time uh
congrats on what you're you've done post
career you you know you mentioned nick
wright obviously uh first things first
and then i am athlete youtube page
everything that you're doing uh i'm
thrilled to see it and then
um as you know uh with the combine
coming up and my run after that
how do i get on
i am athlete how do i get booked on i am
athlete um brandon
you know because you launched
the la i would love to come out there
and sit down with you with swaggy p
yeah
yeah uh brandon jennings our guys yeah
so i would love to have you sit down
with them because you've seen it you've
seen it seven years it's been like seven
years
you've seen it first of all more than
that you've seen it firsthand brandon
that i am athlete you've seen it in your
own two hours got that video again yes
sir you got to drop that video yep you
taught me the one thing that you i
definitely picked up from you because
you know how to to speak and and get
through to people was the idea of make
sure that your fingers you don't ball
your hands up when you run
and you need to take um it's like eating
potato chips
so you said it was like holding a potato
chip in your hand and eating it i
totally got the concept everything else
went way over my head
so
yeah you know
thanks for the call brandon you'll be
well do it
you're the best you take care that at b
marshall thank you guys take care that's
brandon marshall everybody ladies and
gentlemen brandon marshall twitter and
instagram marshall
that i am athlete page millions of
people are watching
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here